natural recipes really kind of pose a
not a problem for us but it's definitely
something that we take a lot more time
with because they are often untranslated
even if they translated into English the
the presumption of knowledge or
ingredients is a problem sometimes we
really try to pad in a lot of time for
international recipes and we usually try
to use experts on those cuisines that
are actually either American or have
lived in America's who have a working
knowledge of what Americans use on a
day-to-day levels for instance Asian
recipes can be very difficult and even
ten years ago finding something like non
pas or knock ma'am which are both kind
of fish fish paste we're very difficult
and often times when i worked at other
magazines we'd say oh we can't we can't
use this recipe because people will
never be able to find this now 10 years
later people can find these ingredients
so that that's one easier thing but it
is very difficult when we're using when
we're commissioning recipes from around
the world because they're also using
different measurements and grams and
that chef might not have converted it
correctly so it can be very challenging
but that's why we do go through such a
rigorous testing of recipes